[Music]
in fighting games
legacy means a lot it's something that
can be defined
by an incredible play
or even through a rivalry that takes on
a life of its own
oh my god
or it can be immortalized by an infamous
[Applause]
but no matter the game leaving your mark
on its competitive history is something
every player dreams of
it's a sure-fire way to gain recognition
and
respect from both opponents and fans
alike
fighting game is something
so great
however for a three-time eva winner like
carl
perfect legend white getting recognized
isn't the problem
it's getting respect because back in
2015 perfect legends
old-school trash talk invoked the wrath
of a rising star
that refused to give him any this is bad
this is bad tea baggage
and what started as a small online feud
between two mortal kombat greats
quickly escalated into an incident that
would become something
far bigger there's not a day that goes
by that i don't hear about it so how did
a twitter beef turn into a
widely recognized meme and how in the
hell did perfect legend get
13 owed in a first to 10.
come on pl you should walk away now you
should just go home bro
you're not going to come out of this
looking good
all right so if you're unfamiliar with
the blood and guts underworld of mortal
kombat esports
let me introduce you to the man the myth
and the meme that is perfect legend
he's an og fighting game player from
toledo ohio
known for showcasing some flashy moves
in game
and out but it was back in 2006 that
perfect legend
really introduced himself as a force to
be reckoned with when he won his
first evo title playing dead or alive
[Applause]
four
[Music]
not long after that perfect legend
shifted his attention to mortal kombat
cementing himself as one of the best in
the scene by claiming
back-to-back evo titles in 2011 and
2012. here you go c junior with another
opportunity
for legend not blocking correctly there
that's me this is gonna be a huge combo
right here no
[Applause]
oh
2012 grand champion but for as long as
perfect legend has been recognized as a
top player
he's also developed a reputation over
the years for speaking his mind
whether it's about the game or his
opponents i grew up in the jordan era
right where everyone talk trash and
they're
over competitive like that that's that's
where i grew up in and
that's that's me i'm just competitive i
would say that i'm blunt
i'm not gonna lie to anyone i'm gonna be
i'm gonna tell you just how it is but
since 2015
perfect legend's name hasn't been tied
primarily to any of his accomplishments
or to his attitude instead it's become
synonymous with a fateful match that has
ascended
into well legend you see perfect legends
troubles began on twitter when he drew
the attention of dominique
sonic fox maclean a fighting game
prodigy that burst onto the scene in
2014
capturing two evo titles before the age
of 18. anything will do it pull your
dragon tattoos out there glowy
wow very very nice all he needed was
that little wow
i think we can put to rest he's the best
anyway
the beef between the two evo champions
sparked after netherrealm's community
manager tweeted
that you could use any character to win
in mk
a position that perfect legend didn't
exactly agree with
and what they did is they used sonic to
cite their source of you can win with
whoever
and i was like sonic one kitana but
katana got
like maybe a laundry list of buffs
before that event and
sonic caught wind of the conversation
and i guess initially began to think
that i was trying to discredit
so then we started talking trash and
things escalate
now perfect legend's original tweet may
not have been targeted
at sonic fox but it was on
both players agreed to play an
exhibition match at summer jam 9 to
settle the dispute
and the event began to generate some
serious buzz
now when you face another player in a
tournament setting you typically play a
short set involving a maximum of three
or five games but the first to ten is a
fighting game tradition that changes
that you know first attends
one of the reasons why a lot of people
like first and tens or kind of
you know treat them as super important
is because it gives
people a chance to adjust and it makes
sure that people feel like
it's more accurate in terms of who's a
better player
as sonic fox arrived for the match they
promised a clean
10-0 and easy money for those who had
side bets riding on the flashy furries
win
and even though the original challenge
on twitter was about aaron black vs kung
lao sonic fox was allowed to set the
terms
so they picked kitana a bad matchup for
perfect legends kung lao
although i think snyder fox is a heavy
favorite i definitely want peo to win
because you know
i love him i hate him and pl talks
people
listen but she's about mortal kombat
right they definitely listen now the
first round
seems to promise a very close set okay
all right
all right perfect legend looking good oh
man wasted ex there and he ducks the
teleport
and gets the chip kill okay so that was
a pretty close first round that was
very important to establish on both
sides but after a few rounds
and some absolutely brutal kitana combos
from sonic fox
things were starting to look pretty bad
for perfect legend oh my god
at all unbreakable right now all
unbreakable stop
stop 40 almost 40
unbreakable you jump back once uh
and they were about to get much worse
jesus christ again the stutter
the shimmy you said p.o please do
something
this is bad this is bad tea baggage
[Applause]
obviously we have somebody figured out
like that like you know at one point
it gets kind of into a pattern and you
kind of see the same thing over and over
again
and fighting games are about pattern
recognition after all so like at a
certain point i was like oh snap like
this might be
this might be like 10-0 like like about
halfway through man we gotta watch this
good yeah gotta watch this finally after
finding himself down
nine games it looked like perfect legend
might rally back
but that hope disappeared very quickly
oh my god
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen i hope you guys
enjoyed the match yeah i don't think it
lived up to the hype
but i think we may have learned
something here uh i'm sure that sonic
box is gonna make some kind of pop off
it doesn't really matter
anything but that wasn't the end of it
no sonic fox wasn't satisfied with
just a decisive victory they wanted to
rub salt
into perfect legend's wounds you're
really good with kling lao
but i can name two that are better with
each variation which i said before with
dj
oh no you're gonna pop off and then
you're gonna [ __ ] out of sonic fought
anyone else would have probably
swallowed their pride taken the l
and gotten the hell out of the building
as fast as they possibly could but
perfect legend doesn't like everyone
else
no instead he decided to make things
infinitely worse all right first off
sonic fox
i want you to let you know like i've
have many times
since i've talked to you you are [ __ ]
godlike i've been saying that to you
forever
i'm not done i have never
i i have never ever ever ever said he
was a bad player
i never said he sucked uh i said his
fundamentals were bad i didn't say that
yo
come on pl you should walk away now you
should just go home bro
you're not gonna come out of this
looking good
to me i'm like dude i'm done like we
just played a long set whether i got
washed or not
because i even get to the point i was
trying to make but it doesn't matter at
this point big e came on stage he's like
well play right now and it was in that
moment the perfect legend made a
decision
that he would never live down after
being given a thorough beating in front
of the electric philadelphia crowd
he volunteered to sit down and take
another
then i was in another position where
well if i don't act on this i look like
maybe a punk or something to it so i was
like well
i'll play again i don't care it was not
that big of a deal to me but
unfortunately for perfect legend
sonic fox swapping characters did very
little to change
anything throws the cow traps and does
the oh my goodness
why why did you do this yourself
perfectly
oh man a 2-1 series man just working
them now it's so meter burned it's
pretty much over man he's cal trapping
the case gets in his face
he might dive due to cow trap ship but
it didn't matter you're just triple
guarding them oh my god
james will be the fatal i may as well be
the fatal right
oh perfect legend come on man come on
guys
one game please bro people are chanting
13-0 in the venue
are you serious sonic fox's asking me
for the chance and sonic fox was
more than happy to oblige yo oh man
you might lose here and now silent fox
all the meter in the world
does not cancel the command grab this
time this time he tries to jump that's
tagged
he's good that was supposed to be his
round
dude oh my god and the brutal just
because
your biggest stop
i mean like it was kind of like it was
kind of like a pass in the torch moment
so to speak like
at that point in time at that point in
time sonic fox was literally
almost unstoppable like at that game at
that point so i kind of felt like
it was a foregone conclusion perfect
legend lost zero games to 13
and the fgc responded by memeing on the
whole situation
and even his name immediately hell even
lupe fiasco joined in on the fun
see people had an affinity of of
of seeing champions like fall and fail
like no matter what they are just they
love seeing it
they like seeing the rise of a champion
the fallen champion i just so happen to
be
the one falling on that day to them in
the years that have passed since the
incident
sonic fox has gone on to cement
themselves as arguably the greatest
multi-game competitor the fgc has ever
seen
their 13-0 in this infamous first to 10
is but a footnote and a legacy that
continues to grow with added silverware
but for perfect legend
the incident is far more than that it's
transformed into a haunting joke that
has sadly become defining
this three-time evo winner isn't
celebrated for his greatest achievements
instead he's endlessly reminded of his
most public failure
there's not a day that goes by that i
don't hear about it
that since that day there's not a single
day unless i turn my entire phone off
and don't go on internet and stuff i
will hear about it i can be
debating a topic that has nothing to do
with fighting games video games in
general
and people will bring up 13-0 like to
dehumanize me or something like i can't
have an opinion it's
i don't know it's kind of ridiculous you
know but in spite of all the ill will
that is
regularly thrown his way perfect legend
remains as committed as
ever to fighting games he's still
competing regularly
organizing events and streaming he might
not have added another
evo title to his trophy cabinet but
there's still time for him to remind
everyone
that he was a legend before he was
turned
into a meme it happens like you know it
is what it is like
i don't think pl story is necessarily
over and like there's certainly there's
certainly time to like rewrite the
history i mean
although at this point in time yes they
will be thinking about pl
at the same time just the fact that
they're bringing up his name every day
even though he got body like definitely
cannot be a bad thing that cannot be a
bad thing you definitely spin that
there are people who are living through
me in that moment and i get that they're
invested
i understand you know i appreciate them
for caring
about the scene and and just the sport
of what we're doing
because that in itself is beautiful so
like that's dope
outside all this that we created
something amazing
i think i think the pause is
just slightly too long between the lines
okay
uh like you can kind of pause with your
mouth open for a little while there
yeah it's like a widely recognized meme